it's a challenge that's foiled
successive home secretaries people
shouldn't be taking this very very
dangerous journey what is happening in
the channel with small boats is unsafe
unfair and unacceptable
the tough talk and joint action plans
haven't worked the numbers crossing the
channel are higher than ever
and in bexley two weeks off a
by-election there's cut through
definitely migrants are more important
than mps having other jobs obviously
trying to earn extra money elsewhere
obviously
immigration is definitely more important
than that i think they're doing enough
to address the issue you know we've got
the borders hopefully sorted out and
moving in the right direction that's
important to me their safety
not necessarily whether or not the
migrants are crossing the channel
definitely would would sway how i vote
it's an issue of growing political
importance to the prime minister who's
now deploying this man the cabinet
office minister steve barclay to bring
together different departments and find
a solution
what country do you come from labour
want more safe routes opened up to help
people fleeing persecution the
government had been looking at
processing migrants offshore in a third
country this week the albanian
ambassador rejected reports of people
could be sent there could the government
legally send migrants to a third country
to be processed
in theory under the refugee convention
they could but the refugee convention
is there to ensure that the government
doesn't return
people to countries where they might be
persecuted or where their fundamental
human rights will be breached we very
much doubt if the government will be
making arrangements for them to be
suitably looked after in these countries
so it will be illegal
we're pretty sure of that
the home secretary had threatened to
pull the 54 million pounds promised to
help french police patrol the beaches
pretty patel met france's interior
minister this monday but trust between
the two sides is fraught i think the
home office needs some help here because
although they are responsible for border
security and border management and
immigration controls this is an
international problem but what's in it
for them on the french side well i think
we need to recognize that france like
many european countries themselves lost
control of their borders there is there
are no borders in the eu and we know
what's happening in the mediterranean we
can see pictures of of migrants messing
on the belarus poland border so we need
agreements with other countries
until then boats keep arriving three
times as many migrants have already
crossed the channel this year compared
to last
pinpointing why we've seen that rise is
hard part of it is thought to be down to
the fact that we haven't seen as many
migrants coming over in lorries and
people smugglers now in many cases see
this route coming in small boats as a
more successful less risky way of making
it to britain but it is by no means a
route without risk and finding a legal
and ethical solution won't be easy for a
prime minister who wants to be tough on
immigration success will be measured by
images like this the flimsy dinghies
left behind in kent and the political
cut-through further afield ali fortescue
sky news